let's go
all right everyone last season was a
smash ratings goal but this year's
script has to top it so welcome to the
table read for the 104th season of the
NFL let's get to work yes Jalen
I thought this was the dress rehearsal
oh sorry week one fourth quarter 302
left Jamar leaps up and makes a
no-handed catch No Hands how I don't
need hands I'll just catch you with my
abs you can call it the Abracadabra
might as well send the ball to Canton
now what if we rode the Mahomes
character out of the script entirely
yeah
it's not cool who said that she did
you're an actor Patrick act like one
boring what if we played shirts versus
skins I like it Kirko what if we replace
my legs with actual Wheels I love it
what if Derrick Henry stiff arms a guy
into another it'd be possible for us to
get to page two